foreign
[Music]
for the Press preview then the first
look at what is on tomorrow's front
pages and tonight we'll check out the
headlines with the Daily Mirror
Economist Susie Boniface and the deputy
editor of conservative home Henry Hill
Susie at least in the festive Spirit
Henry got a bit of catching up to do uh
we'll speak to them in a moment after
we've had a look at the front pages
starting with the i a constitutional
Clash could be in the offing as
politicians in Westminster consider
blocking new legislation already passed
in Scotland that would let people change
their legally recognized gender from the
age of 16.
the telegraph sites the labor leader
secure starman's approval of the
measures while the time says the
government is looking at ways to
encourage older people who may have
taken early retirement back into the
workforce
the financial times is that in the first
20 days of December alone China has
reported 250 million covid cases
amounting to nearly a fifth of its
population
the male criticizes the funding that
goes towards equality and diversity
measures in the NHS
the mirror previews the King's first
Christmas speech in which as one might
expect he pays tribute to his late
mother
while the express says he'll pledge to
build on her Legacy of more than seven
decades on the throne
the son claims his majesty will no
longer be letting prince Andrew keep an
office at Bucking Palace and the star
says that for some reason Russian cyber
hackers have their sights set on the
graffiti artist Banksy
and don't forget by scanning the QR code
you can see on screen throughout the
program you can take a look at
tomorrow's front pages while you watch
us at discussing them and as I say we're
joined tonight by Susie Boniface and
Henry Hill great to see you lots to talk
about then often the papers are a bit
thin this close to Christmas but
actually there is a lot to discuss Susie
starting with this story on the front of
the male a mindfulness lead to help NHS
staff mediate uh is being advertised for
on 40 000 pounds a year someone to act
as a change agent for up to 54
000 pounds according to the mail while
nurses are struggling to heat their
homes and put food on the table
yeah doesn't it sound awful
um now there's only four paragraphs in
the story we've got here so there may be
more inside where there's more detail
that makes some more sense but what
we've got on the front page makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever now the
headline talks about Millions plural
being wasted on these woke jobs the
actual four paragraphs we can see talks
about one million singular now it if
there are some very shonky figures
knocking around for how much it would
cost to give nurses their pay rise and
all the figures come from government and
they've been criticized by a
fact-checking organizations but roughly
speaking we think it would be about just
under 10 billion pounds to give the pay
rise as being asked for to NHS staff now
that wouldn't just be nurses that's
paramedics midwives physiotherapists
lots of different people under the
agenda for change pay scale now that's
just under 10 billion okay and we've got
one million pounds here doing some other
jobs now one million out of that 10
billion that we need is
0.01 percent
it's meanless it's an absolute what why
are we even talking about it now you may
want to say that it's silly to have
something like a mindfulness lead
helping people or nurses to meditate and
they're paying them 40 000 pounds a year
but this is one of those kind of jobs
the meditation is needed it's kind of
one of those things that um gets
encouraged in failing organizations to
try and retain staff who otherwise want
to leave because they're mentally ill
under too much pressure if you actually
pay them properly and retain them and
give them better working conditions they
don't need to down well meditate and you
don't need to persuade them they want to
meditate with a forty thousand pound a
year mindfulness lead what you need to
do is pay those nurses properly in the
first place give them all the NHS staff
the conditions that they need to operate
well so they're not mentally ill and you
won't need to spend a tiny amount of
money that is being spent
proportionately on these things that we
can see in the front four paragraphs of
the Daily Mail yeah um Henry um uh tell
us about this headline and whether you
think it stands up to to any scrutiny
but but but also broaden it out to to
where we are tonight when it comes to
NHS nurses striking
yeah so as far as we know the the NHS
nurse is another medical professionals
are talking about extending strike
action if the government does not come
to the table and negotiate with them
about their current pay demands now the
government has shown so far no
indication that it intends to back down
uh so that means more disruption going
into January now a bit more of this
story is actually on the on the Daily
Mail website we've had a look and
essentially you know you can always find
some jobs which one some of them some of
them might be pointless I think a few
more of them the job descriptions
probably have some slightly vacuous HR
speak but that doesn't necessarily mean
that that job is useless but yeah the
the num the sums involved as a as a as a
share of the money that the NHS needs is
minuscule but I think the really
interesting thing is there you know
there are some conservative MPS quoted
in the story complaining about these
appointments and so on but the thing
that always missed whenever this story
comes up and it comes up with the NHS
and other parts of the public sector all
the time Civil Service often is that the
reason that a lot of these Dei jobs
exist the diversity of quality and
inclusion is because of legislation
which has been honestly mostly the
equality Act of 2010 which has been on
the statute book for the entire time the
conservatives have been in office and
they've not done anything about it right
so I think the question to ask uh
conservative MPS whenever they're
complaining about these sort of jobs is
well if you if you really disapprove of
them and you think they are diverting a
relatively small amount but if you think
they are diverting France away from the
front line why have you the government
not done anything about this legislation
in the 12 years that you've been office
but yeah fundamentally you can find
little irritating things I'm sure in an
organization as big as the NHS there
will be money that's being badly spent
that's almost certain but the fact is
that the solution to these strikes and
the bigger solution towards how we get
an NHS that's fit for purpose these are
Big structural decisions that involve a
lot of money and you're not going to fix
them by playing whack-a-mole with stuff
like this okay um uh there's a a double
page spread in the times unions pile on
pressure to negotiate overpay we'll move
on from the strikes in a moment um Susie
those figures you talking about before
the government agrees with those figures
of course it will cost around an
additional 9.8 billion pounds to give
nurses the 19 pay rise they're asking
for that's six and a half percent of the
total NHS budget
um not just nurses that is that is a
massive chunk of NHS staff that's
everyone on the agenda for change paid
it so it's not just nurses though they
tend to use it to say this is what it
would cost to pay for the nurses asks no
no it isn't yeah Steve Barkley today
saying he urges the unions to reconsider
um still uh very firm in his opinion but
do you think his language is becoming a
little bit more moderate we know earlier
in the week he he described ambulance
unions as making a conscious Choice
didn't need to inflict harm on patients
do you think is there a sign do you
think that maybe uh we could see some
movement before these next two strike
dates by nurses
no I don't think there will be any
movement before then because the
fundamental thing which the the those in
power currently seem to have a problem
with is history and every pandemic every
wave of disease that has come across
Humanity has led to social change and uh
increased rights and demands by the
people who have survived the pandemic so
just taking it back for a moment to the
14th century for you when the Black
Death hit Europe in the early 1300s it
took a while for all the social change
to come out of that because word
traveled slowly but in the 13 about 40
years later we had the peasants revolt
and that was led by the middle classes
it was an uprising against high taxation
unfair taxation and also uh paying
conditions because the serfs who were
peasants who were attached to the land
were objecting unable they were in
demand elsewhere and they could they
suddenly they could move their labor if
they wanted to they wanted to be paid
better so the middle classes and The
Peasants rose up and they ended up
actually dragging the Archbishop of
Canterbury after the Tower of London and
decapitating him all right they
destroyed every tax record in the UK
they sacked the Palace of Savoy and they
forced a boy King to say sorry and say
he'd fix it all now that happens that
kind of thing in different ways happens
after every major new disease and after
this pandemic we knew at the start we
could expect on a much more escalated
quicker scale because of the way our
news travels now for there to be massive
social change as a result and for there
to be economic Kickbacks which would
include people being more employable
more in demand and requiring more money
to be paid and having more rights and
this is how industrial action works it
is not some kind of foreign import it's
not trotskyist it's not some kind of
weird thing the French do that we seem
to have taken on or something like that
this is what English people have done
for centuries when they have you know
when they're more in demand and when
their certain dances chain is to be
expected frankly and the government
needs to realize that what you have to
do to get through that period is to come
to the table do a deal negotiate that's
what it is it's a deal
that was a brilliant history lesson
you've covered hundreds of years of
history in about 30 seconds and
brilliant brilliant Henry listen we're
going to move forward
I want to do one more story before the
break um front page of the eye we know
the Scottish Parliament voted for these
reforms that lower the age uh for when
people can apply to change their legal
gender to 16 years remove the need for
for medical diagnosis as well the
government in Westminster looking at
this very closely
Yeah so basically what's happened is
there's a Devolution in the United
Kingdom is very confusingly done and the
root of this dispute is that the the the
aforementioned equality act which I
discussed in the last thing is a
reserved matter Hollywood the Scottish
Parliament cannot legislate to affect
the equality act but the gender
recognition Act is considered to be a
devolved competence so what the Scottish
Parliament has done is it as you say it
has changed the rules around getting a
gender recognition that if good it's now
much easier and it can be done as a
lower age now the problem this creates
is that suddenly a Scottish a Scottish
issued gender recognition certificate
can be presented to authorities in
England and Wales that's prisons that's
schools that's businesses theoretically
undermining the status of gender law in
England and Wales and so basically what
the government is thinking of doing is
that under the Scotland act under
Section 35 of the Scotland act it can
intervene to prevent bills passed by the
Scottish Parliament from getting a royal
Ascent now that would be hugely
controversial I don't think it's been
done before certainly not very often and
it would set up a clash which the SNP
would love between Westminster and the
Scottish Parliament over the right to
legislate that the Dilemma for
Westminster is that if they don't act
then you risk effectively creating a
two-tier system where prisoners students
and other people who have happened to
get their GRC in Scotland have different
rights have an expedited pathway through
the system uh compared to people in
England and Wales yeah fascinating stuff
isn't it and secure starmer seems to
support that Scottish legislation
according to the front of the Daily
Telegraph thank you both for the moment
plenty more still to come including if
you're taking early retirement could you
be persuaded back into the workforce
apparently the government hope so
discussing that in a couple of minutes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back part two of The Press
preview Susie and Henry still with us uh
Susie front page of the times uh trying
to get over 50s to come back to work
yeah good luck with this Rishi now this
is actually a re-announcement this is
something that was started in July okay
the web page for this on the government
website has been running since then that
was a pilot scheme and they've now
decided to kind of spin it as something
fresh and new but Boris Johnson did this
uh I didn't think that that was oh my
God how many prime minister does it go
but it's only July
um but it's been running for a while but
what they're not taking into account
this mid-life mot which is people who
have stopped working have become
economically inactive in quote marks
which is silly because they're still
spending money aren't they to buy things
but apparently they're economically
inactive because they're not paying tax
and they're not earning
um they uh they need to be given
something a midlife mot to give them
some skills or see what skills they've
got to bring them back into the
workplace according to this Theory and
if you look in the copy there it talks
about tackling and I quote the notion
that um there is a problem with
long-term unemployment rates and
long-term sickness in this country and
that's not a notion that's actually it's
a fact 28 percent of people who were
economically inactive
since the pandemic um I have been
mentally ill before the pandemic it was
15 there has been a junk in mental ill
health and that has been diagnosed by
people it's not imaginary it's not a
notion you've also got people who have
got long covered you have got people who
are once they're over 50 then more like
to become disabled they're more like to
have diseases they're more likely to
have caring responsibilities they're
more likely to be grandparents they're
more likely to not be able to work for
some reason
um and they're also more likely to be
expensive employees once a company gets
rid of someone over 50 they could employ
two people who are 25 so starting saying
they should all come back into the
workplace is a marvelous idea but are
the over 50s going to pick fruit yeah
are they going to drive lorries and are
they going to run the NHS Henry
so obviously anything that could if
there are people who are older and would
like to work but are facing barriers to
get into work then a program to help
those people is great what I don't think
we've seen from the government so far is
much of an Evidence base for how many
people that actually is we know roughly
how many people they're counting as you
know economically inactive because
they're over a certain age but not
working but I don't think we've yet got
a breakdown of you know how many of
these people are we actually trying to
help and I think that some people in the
conservative party will also be slightly
concerned that this is a very sort of
Treasury brain view in which every
single person is viewed purely through
the lens of you know are they working
good that's a policy success are they
not working for whatever reason bad
that's a policy failure you know as I
said some people have caring
responsibilities now that means that if
you take them back into you know back
into the economy back into employment
that means that you need to find more
carers from somewhere to pick up the
slap that also means that people who are
for example stay-at-home parents
um if they go back you need to find more
care for them care is extremely
expensive and in short supply so yes
this is a well-intentioned scheme and if
the government has evidence that there
is a substantial number of people who
fit what I think are a quite narrow
range of criteria that's great and it
should be fully supported but I think
there are two problems with it one an
awful lot of people who show up on the
dashboard as economically enacted
probably have very good reasons for
being so and two if you bring some of
those people back into the workforce you
actually there's a bit of a waterbed
effect in your V8 pressure elsewhere
okay and let's just finish we've just
got a about 30 seconds Susie it's the
same store in the front of the Daily
Express Kings vow to build on Queen's
Legacy and Christmas speech and the
front of the mirror always close to Mama
uh the king is going to deliver his
speech from Saint George's Chapel in
Windsor
yes as close as he could get to his
mother which
um may be sweet for some people and a
bit gruesome for others uh we're gonna
have to wait and see of course some of
entirely of what he said uh but it's the
first time he's gonna do it and of
course this does show that the age of 73
it is possible to finally get a job
Henry one sentence
yeah I mean I think it's probably very
weird for most of us to be saying the
King after having grown up all our lives
saying the queen God knows what it must
be like for him
um Good Luck okay um thank you both very
much indeed King Charles will pledge to
build on the Glorious Legacy of his
darling Mama according to the Daily
Express